when you're writing a story how much do
you think about developing a story world
yeah I mean I think that's a fundamental
for stories it doesn't matter whether
it's fantasy or like a realistic drama
like you're always going to be building
a world you know around these people
that's believable doesn't necessarily
have to be true but it you know you want
to try to make it
believable um and uh yeah I just think
that's that's always in question you
know it's like what is the world what
are the rules that are happening in this
world like you know I feel like that's a
fundamental that you're always trying to
achieve what are some Essentials for
building a story World I'll call them
guidelines I don't like rules or you
know or like uh but I think like the uh
the rules of the world itself this is a
guideline but the rules of the world
itself you know for instance like you
know you do X why is going to happen you
know it's just like this is how this
world Works see you know for instance
like if you're making a fantasy it's
like well if they say this holding the
staff then like or the one then this is
going to happen right it's just like now
the audience understands like in this
world like you know magic right you know
so um or in another one where it's just
like no this is the real world it's like
well the rule is like there's no magic
in this world right it's just like so um
I think understanding that and kind of
attacking that is always like uh it's
crucial or like as a guideline you know
it's like you can do what you want but
these are I feel like stuff like that
these are like guidelines to for you to
rely on you know that you can always
fall back on how much of the world you
built with the angry black girl and her
monster started with the script all of
it yeah I mean well I guess no I guess I
couldn't say all of it
um yeah I mean a lot of it starts with
the script you know you're describing
things and you're you know you want to
make sure everyone involved gets the
gets the message you not the message of
the story but just like the message or
the vision of what is trying to be
created that's what you hope you know at
least that's what I hope when I you know
write the script and then obviously the
the the keys or the um the creative Keys
come on and and and bring that to life
and bring their own spin on it but
they're all jumping off of the script
itself you know so what is the story
world the story world I mean it's a uh
uh to me it's grounded in in reality as
much as it can you know possibly be you
know it's like to me or uh the
believability that it's happening you
know next door and to me the world that
it needed to take place in the reason
was because I needed to see um where the
fiercest uh results of like systemic
pressure you know is happening you know
this isn't a like um a one-off or
whatever it's just like this is the
result result of systemic pressure so to
me this was the best place to uh to
Showcase that and did you get a choice
as to the location you wanted a certain
town a certain F yeah and it was this
one like they you know CU originally I I
thought you know I wanted to shoot in LA
but you know they we were locations
counting and seeing you know a bunch of
different options and then we came here
and I was like this is uh this is the
spot this is pretty much exactly what I
wrote in the the script so yeah and so
how far apart were these different
locations CU it takes place in some
apartments and then there's other parts
how far away geographically were they
like in the story or in real life in
real life yeah how close um they were
actually fairly close fairly close to
each other like literally down the
street interesting okay so in terms of
when ficaria goes into her I guess you
would call it Studio or her she's like
Frankenstein and so how much did you get
a say in that world and how much were
you already envisioning writing on the
page because that was a very Vivid world
yeah it was beautifully created yeah I
mean that was due to our um our
production designer you know shout out
to Mark bankins Hire that guy okay yeah
that was really cool yeah you know I was
just kind of like I told him like this
you know this shouldn't look like she
has access to stuff cuz she don't you
know she's she's in high school no high
schooler would have access to like this
kind of CR this madness unless they were
you know some kind of billionaire or
something like you know I don't know but
even then you know why would unless the
parents are just completely neglectful
you know it's like it's just there's too
many Dynamics or whatever right uh so I
just want I was like this needs to be a
space of of of you know she's inventive
but she's using what she can find you
know your set designer was Mark bin how
much did you work with him to create her
lab and this lab was at her home or the
apartments yeah it was in the complex
yeah yeah no me and uh bankins we had
long conversations about it about what
was you know the color space the how it
was built what you know what was in
there and um yeah long you know a lot of
long conversations about the direction
of you know where it was going what it
was going to be so did you storyboard
and Did you sort of draw out this lab no
I I can't draw worth than nothing so
like I was it was me just like speaking
and and saying and giving some kind of
reference images you know that was what
I that was what I could do okay so you
you saw it in your head and then you
kind of conveyed that to Mark yeah yeah
yeah was there push back on well it
should be this way that way it's too
Fantastical or this was all about sort
of suspending disbelief that this young
woman would have a lab like this no like
um I mean it's a Frankenstein story so
you know it's like there's going to be
some I believe there'll be some leeway
there you know and I think when you buy
into her her Brilliance you know if you
buy into that then you buy into what she
can what she can accomplish you know so
um yeah how long did it take to build
the set of the lab man I can't speak for
I'm not sure I think it man I don't know
it wasn't it couldn't have been too long
I'm I'm hoping it was just like I think
it was like a couple
weeks I think you know for the sets that
we built I think it was a couple weeks
but
yeah and how long was the actual film
shoot about 20 days 20 days in North
Carolina was this in the summer yep uh
June last year okay yeah but the weather
was uh decent or um we hit some uh
thunderstorms and stuff there some of
that happened down there so but it was
hot yeah were there any other important
elements to building the story world I
don't think so I mean I think like you
know just understanding the players and
uh understanding the world she's
inhabiting and who she's interacting
with and you know her life I think all
those things were
just those things are important yeah and
I like what you said how with the story
world even though there's not really any
rules on how to do it but that you're
establishing these are sort of like the
the things in the world so if a happens
then B is going to follow and you keep
consistent with that yeah try I think
that that's a that's a fundamental
guideline you know it's like that I
think um uh as artist like you know it's
like you know it's fall back on you know
that you want to and you know that I
want to at least I'd like to achieve you
know I'm trying to achieve you know I
think an audience can feel robbed when
stuff stops making sense it can take you
out of it you know unless that's your
goal you know if your goal isn't to have
them fall out of the movie or whatever
then uh I think guidelines like these
can help you you know how did the way
you film the movie bring the story world
to life I mean that was a combination of
Daphne and I shout out to Daphne hire
her too
DP yeah yeah excellent work yeah uh she
was phenomenal on this uh she did such a
good job a great job and um I think it
came down to just always dialing in on
character motivations and what shots are
going to give us the most impact for
what we're seeing you know like I I try
to think about that stuff you know of
course there's like trick shots that you
want to do or whatever but you also want
that to be involved with the the
emotional like trajectory of the story
as well I think you know and I think
um I mean I hope the visuals impacted in
in that
way